filmed a commercial at home with friends
this time so a while ago my friend
preethi made a pencil commercial for a
class and she enlisted me as its
cinematographer for these shots i dug up
a sketch i did back in like 8th grade
and lightly drew over it here i brought
my trusty fidget spinner back and mass
it out in post later the voiceover was
by another super talented friend perovi
i think it really tied the whole thing
together without further ado here is the
final commercial
i'm your dixon tickonderoga number two
pencil
yes the forgotten pencil laying around
somewhere in your house
i'm here watching when you try to use a
pen that runs out of ink or when your
computer crashes and you can't take any
more notes
or even when the lead in your mechanical
pencil breaks
so let's not forget that traditional
never disappoints
number two but always number one
dixon
i filmed an actual commercial at home so
a few weeks back i was hired to market
an eyebrow hair remover so i threw
together a makeshift set with a couple
bed sheets and got to work for this shot
yes that is a fidget spinner i wanted to
give a pen an illusion of flying through
the air and just mask it out while
editing for this closing sequence i just
took a bunch of shots with a pen in
random places and stitch them together
without further ado here is the final
commercial
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
filmed an actual commercial at home part
two recently i was hired to market some
mini pet glasses so i went to a nearby
park and gathered some pine cones and
branches for a holiday themed video for
this shot i hooked a piece of black
string to these glasses and taped it to
my light to make it appear as if it were
floating here i created a stop-motion
sequence with all the glasses i had on
top of a wooden cutting board without
further ado here's a final commercial
let me know what you think
[Music]
[Music]
i was bored and craving guacamole the
other day so i decided to make some and
film the process in this clip i am
trying so hard to get smooth footage and
this is how it turned out so i spent
like an hour trying to fix that in post
here i wanted to make it look as if the
tomato was falling apart in midair so i
stitched two separate clips together i
actually really like how it turned out
without further ado i present cinematic
guacamole
[Music]
you